good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday now if
you're watching on youtube i don't want
to scare you i really really don't but i
need to issue a trigger warning because
claudia is wearing her spooky scary
skeleton pajamas and for all those of
you listening as a podcast it might be
the reason to switch to youtube today
no it or it might not be if you're
feeling already like the sunday scaries
might have scared you off
stay far away
from the youtube channel of the morning
toast and definitely don't subscribe to
our channel oh no
that's spooky
yes i'm wearing my spooky scary
skeletons and shivers down your spine um
i don't know i was just feeling it i
slept in these pajamas and i usually
like i do my makeup in my pajamas and
then i put on right like an appropriate
sweater or a blouse but i thought what's
more appropriate for a monday than
spooky scary skeletons sending shivers
down your spine it's a spooky monday i
think you capture the vibe plus your
glam is so on point today that it really
it balances you have balance in your
look so firmly believe in living a
balanced lifestyle that's kind of what
my whole brand is about um yes my glam
is on point today because i just have
the busiest day meetings meetings
meetings meetings meetings meetings i
think you might have forgotten that
tomorrow let me just make sure of the
date
tomorrow
is the uh launch of my paperback book so
i've got some press to do today
i have uh yes yeah your girl i don't
know if i should say it i didn't even
tell you yet already but i'm just gonna
be on like a local not a local a
national news segment that's so exciting
i need to set my tivo but the tivo the
number one reason i'm wearing glam like
this is because i did a tick tock this
morning like a transition using my new
song and it came out
so good because i looked like gorgeous i
didn't really intend to look like that
this gorgeous like this threatening to
other women but check out my tick tock
okay you have to send it to me when you
i feel like you only send me like the
mediocre tic tacs because you're like is
this funny or is this not but like send
me the bangers i didn't realize like i
was capable of putting out mediocre tick
tocks that's brand new information it
happens it happens
not
not everyone can hit obviously no that's
true because like some of them need to
be mediocre in order for the others to
be great otherwise there's no nothing to
compare it to yeah for sure
well while you're wearing your spooky
scary skeletons let me just tell you how
cool i am today you probably think like
oh you're just wearing a hoodie like
yeah you're phoning it in this is the
gap yeezy hoodie
what did you pay for it uh zach got it
for me so it's a gift it doesn't count
yeah but also it's gap prices i think it
was mac i think it was like eighty
dollars oh okay eighty dollars can you
do a spin for us
um sure it's just blue
it's just blue and like there's
something it's really um thick and heavy
but like in a nice comfortable way
and it's kind of like cropped so i think
i'm wearing a large but it looks like a
fitted sweatshirt got it got it okay
cool i would say that in person yeah no
definitely come come check it out did
you get my reference eighty dollars from
my show right yeah but that that okay
jackie loves to quote my comedy special
which is so kind of you available to
stream for free on amazon prime
that um didn't make it it didn't make
the cut i only used it in like one show
and like it wasn't great but you were
really kind of moved by it i was it
stuck out to me you can't colors you can
help what lives in your mind rent-free
and this is why i have to see your new
tour because i need new material i
actually can't believe that you have not
seen my new tour i've i saw the first
show
the first new york show on video yes
um
but yeah no beyond that i know that it's
changed a lot and i i don't know the
tropes i don't know the one-liners and
that's also like happening this week i'm
back on the road i'm going to dc on
thursday and friday to parks casino in
philly and i'm actually really excited
like i really like taking long breaks
between shows but then like when it's
the day before the show i'm like oh my
god i wish my last show wasn't over a
month ago yeah but it's fine you've got
your your skeleton boys with you you'll
take them on the road they've got your
back
and your front and my side and my crotch
um we have a great show for you guys
it's monday lots of happenings that we
must discuss also lots of tv recap i did
finish ted lasso i have a lot of
thoughts on the tv recap i watched
euphoria last night and then of course
the worst show on television with not a
hero in sight the real housewives of
salt lake city um we'll be discussing
that in the tv recap as well you needed
to finish ted lasso because
what you left us with on friday your
assessment yeah i just needed to be able
to talk about it i won't spoil it we'll
talk about in the tv recap but it needed
to be addressed and i couldn't let you
think like keep going like that no
you're 100 right yeah so that's really
exciting that you
[Music]
don't let them talk it how's the song
going great i mean the tick tocks are um
they're difficult for me because i'm
really not a dancer after our show on
friday i like spent 30 minutes learning
the tick tock dance to my song and it's
up it's not great but i tried you know
it was i thought it was i thought it was
good okay okay thank you it was a
complex dance you know not your typical
basic tik-tok dance it's not like other
dances no it's not but would you expect
anything less from someone who's not
like other girls i wouldn't
so there you have it um so i hope
everyone had a good weekend listening to
the song drinking i did nothing this
week and i felt like you like i did not
leave my house
i didn't move a muscle like if you
watched my instagram stories yesterday
you know that i had 91 steps at the end
of the day
and i was very proud of that
sometimes that self-care looks like 91
steps
i couldn't have said it better but i do
think more often than not self-care
looks like hard work the more i think
about self-care and like the meaning of
it i think the term has really become
like completely um watered down but i do
think most often self-care looks like
hard work i agree because for me when
i'm like busy booked productive
that is really unfortunately when i feel
my best and when i'm doing nothing even
though i'm enjoying it at the time i go
through an existential crisis like is
this what my life is meant to be yeah so
sometimes you have to put in the work in
order to enjoy true self-care how are
you feeling today pregio
i'm feeling pretty good you know
mornings are my time to shine it's so
i'm two different people like i'm hannah
montana and miley stewart like in the
morning
i am hannah and then in the evening i'm
crabby old miley no you're like jackson
it's so it's so crazy but you know it's
we're just enjoying this time
but it's a wild ride you guys it's a
journey my weekend was um filled with
hobbies actually i got a lot done first
of all i started playing wordle thanks
to you oh did you do today's no not yet
me neither i started it and it's pretty
hard i'm only on i only did two tries
already oh i try to like do it you know
in one sitting i don't know why i feel
like someone's timing me they're not um
and i usually do it in one sitting too
but i was just like doing my makeup i'm
like oh my god wordle
oh wow no i'll save that for later it'll
be my big activity it's very exciting um
and i also i did a crossword puzzle i've
been
doing piano lessons me and bro do about
like 30 minutes a day we have two pieces
that we're working on what you're doing
tickling the ivories
bruce like mom you stink mom you're off
but no by the way you know how he does
that thing with his head he like [ __ ]
it to the right when he's yeah when
he'll be practicing like playing a wrong
note and you'll turn around and bruise
like
yeah no he's a really tough critic but
it's been good for the brain and then i
started a new show which a lot of people
told me i would like it's called poldark
and it's on amazon prime it's a period
piece you know uh
cornwall
1785. and it's good it's it's enjoyable
so it's kind of slow so like i can't
just watch it all day long but i'm in
the middle of season two and there's
some likeable characters so i'm happy
okay good yeah we both had both
productive and relaxing weekends
precisely that's wonderful news would
you love to hear it
um
so yeah like that's really it for me
i've not much to update everyone on
since friday because i didn't leave my
bed since the last time we podcasted
yeah i feel kept abreast and i feel like
without further ado to do
we can get into
you where is doo doo doo doo on the bed
right there behind me
i would like turn my screen and show you
my bed but there's something about like
showing someone like your youtube
channel like your bed and i haven't
staged this side of the room i only
stage what's behind me like feels very
personal and invasive it's all wrong
don't do it it is right okay i'm not
doing it yeah that's like when you go to
someone's house and they like want to
show you around and and they want to
show you their parents room it's like
i'll wait by the door
i'll just wait outside that's a sweet
right here oh i went down the block you
like poke your head in and you're like
nice
hi mrs stevenson i think like there's
something crazy about like kids who like
invite their friends into their parents
rooms it just feels very personal i
totally agree so that's what's going on
to my left got it we won't go into your
room without further ado to do it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
helium 10. is anyone looking for a
career change and alternative to the
traditional nine-to-five or you're an
entrepreneur who wants to start a
business on your own terms well you got
to check out helium10 they will teach
you how to build a thriving ecommerce
business from a to z it's an all-in-one
software suite that's designed to help
entrepreneurs launch manage and scale a
profitable e-commerce business on amazon
and walmart.com there's a community of
over a million users and they have all
the tools data and training to be
successful the great thing about helium
10 is like okay i want to be my own
business owner but like i don't have a
business to own they do everything for
you you don't even need to invent a
product the helium 10 tools will help
you find a product source it and then
tap into amazon's existing customer base
product demand and shipping
infrastructure to launch the business
they handle all the shipping and the
returns for you you are merely just
doing what they tell you it's amazing
you can really really change your life
it's free to join it's not just a trial
offer your free account includes ongoing
monthly access to helium 10's most
popular tools at no cost to you it has
been used by over a million people
worldwide and they sell goods directly
to amazon
and amazon's customer base of 5 billion
shoppers so work when you want from
wherever you want with the help of
helium 10. join the over a million
helium 10 users worldwide by signing up
for a free account at
helium10.com toast that's
slash
helium10.com
today's episode is also brought to you
by ballen branch the best
best sheets on the market take it from
someone who i think on average spends
more time in her bed than any human
being walking this earth
you're going to want to check out bowlin
branch the best betting out there their
signature sheets feel so soft and light
you will really forget you're not
actually sleeping on a cloud they're
sustainably made for uncompromising
quality from field to factory so if you
dream of comfortable sheets or you're
very particular about your sheets like i
am i really don't like like there are
sheets that are really nice and lovely
and warm but you like
die of sweat in the middle of the night
golden branch has somehow managed to
have like delicious soft warm sheets
that also keep you cool throughout the
night
the
temperature control from their buttery
soft lightweight organic cotton is just
stunning it actually gets softer over
time with the more times you wash it
which is nice and it's not too hot it's
not too cold it's really the perfect
year-round sheet for most sleepers
they focus on quality over quantity so
they don't give you inflated thread
counts because more isn't always better
they're also made to a higher standard
the sheets are 100 organ organic cotton
excuse me oh my god
ethical production and thoughtful
attention to every detail they also give
you a fair price plus a 30-day risk free
trial with free shipping and returns so
experience the best sheets you'll ever
feel at bowlingbranch.com
get 15 off your first set of sheets when
you use promo code toast at checkout so
that's bowlin branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code toast
thank you so much claudia before we get
into the stories we actually do need to
talk about something and it's a bit of
sports news oh we do because sports were
on last night football it was like the
semi-finals and
we were sorry you were very close
you're we both made predictions for who
we thought we would be would be in the
super bowl we made them months ago when
there was like no real information just
you know taking a shot in the dark and
up until last night like you had a
chance a pretty good chance bucks versus
bills bucks first bills now the bucks
are out which is and and the best oh
okay okay yeah no last night was not a
good night for my fantasy
chart
right but i just want to congratulate
you for having made it that far i think
that's pretty cool considering you know
our lack of knowledge
like
right and so before we get into the fast
five i think we need to put in our
predictions we need to update them based
on the information that's given okay
here's the thing i'm not gonna
i don't wanna predict i wanna put my
full
support behind one team and once you
hear why jackie you're going to want to
do the same okay so here's who's
contending still we have the rams
the 49ers versus the 49ers and then
kansas city versus uh team um
whoever beat the bucks no frick what's
their name it's like uh
it's two charades no i
oh i mean i could do an animal espn i
think so it's like a weird animal it
feels like and it's not a team we talk
about often a jaguar
this is no no no
this is infuriating i know people on the
other end are probably like these two
morons
okay
who beat the box babe
zach i can't i'll just look at that
pulled up just call husbands
i don't think he can hear me
they're the ones who beat the buccaneers
yeah babe who's in the super bowl
oh sorry we're recording but it's so
it's rams versus 49ers
oh my god okay sorry oh my god tell him
to just get on with it ramsay's 49ers
and chiefs
bengals that's the animal i'm unfamiliar
with their work yeah that's right
but i do want to say that we at the
toast have made an official decree as to
who we're supporting
we have and you're going to get behind
it once you i totally forgot to tell you
this okay
we are rooting for
the san francisco 49ers
it's their time
there is
a toaster
on the team on the field and off the
field i just found this out last night
from ben there's a toaster on the field
his name is kyle
gooscheck
his wife is an enormous toaster and he
messaged ben
that his wife is a toaster and he
actually listens quite a lot and he
enjoys it
kyle use check the 49ers have our
support
oh my god of course i'm throwing all of
my weight behind them now
he's like really good too it's not like
he's like you know a scrub
yeah wow okay that's so interesting so
you're saying it's the 49ers time
i'm saying and i do believe the last
time i accurately predicted a super bowl
i predicted that it was not the 49ers
time right now i'm saying it is that's
so interesting because before i knew
this important factor that changes
everything
i would have said like i would probably
have chosen the rams over the 49ers and
also because the super bowl is taking
place in l.a it would be like another
cool thing where you know the home team
is having hosting the super bowl it's
still california so i just want to say
it's still pretty cool
yeah still pretty cool and then on the
other side i think the chiefs will beat
the bengals considering i couldn't even
remember their name me too and i just
want to say like for my pov i really was
like a chiefs girly
um
until the lead quarterback um patrick
and his brother like
you know i've come on here many times
and talked about his brother's tic-tock
yeah yeah no i know he i know him by
name austin jackson
i know him by name that's not the same
it's jackson austin
that's the second time in as many weeks
his name has come up literally
well his brother um you know i'm always
a fierce defender of jackson mahomes i
think the kids on tick tock are really
mean to him but you know what like his
content has taken a shift and it's like
really painful to watch and i think that
he should stop
okay and you think like going to the
super bowl it just won't it wouldn't be
good for him no because i think of the
content
that we're gonna get at the super bowl
and i'm not interested
okay and we also like already got that
yeah so he's someone else's turn he
needs a new stick i just hate when
there's like one team that's like so
good all the time like i get it because
like
patrick is the best but like it's kind
of annoying but i don't think any of
these four teams are the one team that's
good all the time i think the chiefs are
actually like they're always just like
winning no i think they're really strong
and solid but they won the one time they
like it could be their time again no but
like it's not like these patriots are
always at the top of their game like
they're giving early vibes of the
patriots that's what i'm saying
no i don't feel that way but i
understand that you might know more than
you yeah
no i think i do i have just an intuition
for these things oh yeah remind me who
who were your picks again for who was
going to the super bowl
seahawks
it's the 49ers time you heard it here
first front page of page six sports
tomorrow it's a 49ers time okay very
cool we're wishing we're sending our
best wishes to all the toasters in
locker rooms all over don't get it
twisted there are actually
quite a few toasters ready when i go on
tour
i find out where like the professional
athletes who are toasters are they that
come out of the woodwork when i was in
new orleans
i found out will lutz the kicker for the
saints who's very good well his wife's a
toaster but he came to the show he's so
cute she was so cute nice to know that
new orleans is taken care of with the
steeny vibes yeah for sure but there
aren't i can't imagine there are that
many athletes listening male athletes
listening to toast it's it's you know
it's the wax
i wouldn't say that i wouldn't say that
you really never know look at kyle use
check look at kyle use check okay
can't wait i have to get a jersey
literally with the toast logo
cute cause like it's the super bowl but
like between us like it's really about
us right
it's always about us i'm so glad we are
on the same page
now i think we can get into the past
five stories i just needed to update
everyone yeah no i'm glad we we circled
back
our first story um a lot of news coming
out this weekend about garrett hedlund
and emma roberts first of all they split
up and second of all he has been
arrested for public intoxication
okay am i crazy or has this entire
series of events like already happened
uh
not to me
some of it cut up before yeah they i
always assumed they were on off i didn't
know that they were on and now they're
off and um then he was arrested for
public intoxication saturday night in
tennessee but he also is in a suit of a
prior dui he's had like drunken behavior
criminal behavior before so there's
this is not the first time something
like this has happened but he was
arrested and taken into custody in
franklin county with the bond set at
2100. franklin county is so nice
the arrest occurred just one day after
news broke that he split from girlfriend
emma roberts the two share one child
together one-year-old son rhodes
according to people who was the first to
break the news on friday they called it
quits a few weeks ago following a few
rocky months in their relationship an
insider said it's sad and they are
trying to call they're trying their best
to co-parent it's been hard
also he is being sued for negligence
after allegedly causing a head-on
collision when he fell asleep at the
wheel while driving in la in january
2020. in court docks obtained by e news
he allegedly passed out behind the wheel
of his vehicle and ran a solid red light
at a high rate of speed forcing him to
crash into a woman and her daughter
yeah so now he's being sued so
this is what that means
you're done with him that and this one's
this is like what i was saying with
tiffany haddish sometimes it's easier
than others like sam hunt
very easy to write off
tiffany haddish a little hard this
extremely hard garrett headlund is the
star of two of my favorite movies what's
the second one country strong oh and
georgia rule georgia rule and did you
know he was in the friday night lights
movie
i never saw it me neither but they
called him the friday night lights actor
and so i had to google it okay that's a
stretch and a half he's clearly the
country strong actor yeah so anyways
this is all just crazy timing i do
believe that they broke up a while ago
and then this story was dropping and
emma wants nothing to do with this
so now news of their split is
resurfacing but and we must have known
this january 2020 dui news back in
january 2020 and just like yes no i'm
telling you i've heard this before right
so this man needs help like yeah serious
help no wonder his relationship with his
the mother of his child's rocky like
he's unwell yeah
yeah this is really [ __ ] up i'm sorry
china like i can't really [ __ ] with you
anymore garrett and i know how much you
know that probably means to you but this
is really upsetting this is upsetting
truly what are you doing i just i can't
go on another rant but like it's just
not that hard to not drink a drive like
especially when you get paid millions of
dollars for one movie yeah well most
this one on saturday night was public
intoxication but like if you're getting
arrested for being drunk like you're
just like your drinking is it's not that
it should be
yeah
if i haven't gotten arrested for public
intoxication really nobody should
okay and i think that's a good test
okay
are you ready for our next story a
little more couple news
nick jonas and wife priyanka chopra
welcomed a baby girl as they announced
the arrival of their first child
together via surrogate we are overjoyed
so on friday nick and pre put out a
statement saying that they have a babe
girl that they welcomed via surrogate
last week and they're just overjoyed
yes there's actually a lot to this story
that is beyond the just quote card that
they posted their baby was born 12 weeks
early yes i saw that they were expecting
baby to be due in april according to
daily mail and
it's january so always really scary yeah
but i'm sure that they have the best
care and we're all rooting for them yeah
for sure and then on tick tock people
are quaking like i've somehow ended up
on like nick and priyanka talk
um and they're quaking about you know in
the article it says like uh priyanka
hasn't struggled with any fertility
issues just like scheduling wise like
they decided to go be a surrogate and
people are like you know this is so
offensive to like women who struggle
with fertility and like i guess but like
if that was me and like i was working
and being famous and i also wanted to
have a child like
how great is that
you know i thought we were like done
judging women [ __ ] like this yeah i mean
that sounds like nick talk is a little
bit uh aggressive
regressive over there and also sure
that's what that said but you never know
what's going on with people right what
does page six know about priyanka
chopra's fertility right like it it's
not just like an on off button like you
can or you can't like there's so many
different factors that go into it and so
much like i i just
she's also a woman of a certain age
which obviously changes the risk of the
pregnancy like who cares like literally
who cares right exactly so
i'm happy for them this is really sweet
i mean obviously like the joe bros love
just family and and having and now like
this is just so cute all the little
cousins will be running around no it is
really cute it like completes a trifecta
and it actually officially like makes us
old
you do you think this is what makes us
old nick was the youngest like and like
when when he came into our lives like he
was actually prepubescent and like no he
has a child
yeah well he's 29. no i mean it's he's
on track no no it makes sense yeah
but like for us
it just it puts things in perspective
how about that yeah and i guess like all
of the girly girls were like going to
the tour because like back in the day
like the way we're obsessed it's like
and some of those girly girls are still
single like we're holding out hope that
maybe they were the one for nick jonas
and like this priyanka thing wasn't
gonna last yeah but no this is
definitely all three
they were taken and if you need another
sign they are taken yeah maybe it's time
to get into a new band
yeah
what's the new band i don't know what's
that band that's like everywhere ajr
they're cool new rock band you should
check them out you know about a cool new
rock band i do
what is it
they sing that song don't
you know that song no you do it's really
cool with the kids everyone's talking
oh is it no i swear i swear i believe
you i swear it was in the car commercial
for kardashians last season
if you heard it you would have my
friends if you heard it you would know
it yeah for sure but i'm not clear what
you're talking about at this current
moment well you're a guest you're just
not as up on what's cool no it's
possible like i'm not as gensy as you
it's called ajr check them out ajr okay
i'll check them out i think
um
also what was the lesson i was gonna say
oh you know what like
from the moment that these two got
together like there has been so much
doubt and myself included like i have to
take responsibility for my actions like
there has been so much doubt
um
even like when they were engaged are
they even gonna get married but you know
through every
life stage like they have just
persevered
and you know what i'm here to say i was
wrong and there are a lot of people out
there who are wrong who like still
refuse to admit they're wrong that's
crazy i mean i am i came around to it
over a year ago like and i already have
admitted that i was wrong and i'm happy
to be wrong about this one because they
just seem like really happy and watching
the roast most recently i feel like that
was like the biggest glimpse we've had
into their relationship and like
they are just
they're the real deal they're the real
deal like it's time we all got on board
honestly yeah if you're one of the
people who's like lagging behind you've
got to get on the ship it's the ship's
like the world's biggest denier like no
ever yeah no it's crazy how we felt then
yeah like there was and that was also at
a time when like so many celebrity
relationships popped up and turned into
engagements that fizzled out really
quickly ariana and pete ariana and pete
haley and justin
and i just like threw these two in the
boat with them and i was like yeah we're
not going anywhere yeah and then like
the wedding was like legit and then they
just never stopped being married so we
have no choice but to believe
yeah no doubters non-believers
once were her dreamers exactly
very very happy for them that was some
exciting surprising news
very surprising because like it just
came out of nowhere it's not like we're
pregnant it's like oh there's a child
yeah
okay our next story is very sad regina
king's son has died by suicide ian
alexander jr the only son of renowned
actress regina king has died by suicide
the academy award winner confirmed the
tragic news in a statement to people on
friday they said our family is
devastated at the deepest level by the
loss of ian he is such a bright light
who cared so deeply about the happiness
of others our family asks for respectful
consideration during this private time
thank you
this is just awful this is such an awful
story his 26th birthday was on wednesday
he was regina's only child
with um her ex-husband and i mean this
just like breaks the heart the mental
health crisis i know
in this country right now is not to be
ignored yet it is like and i saw on like
a page six article you know he had some
like haunting last post on social media
and some of the tweets he had sent out
before you know
before um were like you know instagram's
bad for my health like it was just
really like a cry for help yeah no it's
really upsetting and i also
i feel like in the last even few days or
a week like so many celebrities have
passed away yes also chris daughtry's
daughter uh my god so sad passed away
last week too
meatloaf i don't think we spoke about
him ben was really like on the verge of
tears when he heard me left eyed i
didn't know last night terry mugler
right right i didn't know ben was such a
big meatloaf fan until i saw his um
oh my god have you never been like in a
karaoke machine with ben i guess not
honestly i would do
it
and it's like an eight-minute song it's
so [ __ ] annoying oh yeah and that's
really ben's um like his key yeah oh
yeah yeah it's his perfect pitch
i can hear him singing it it's one of
the most annoying things ever and like
especially when we get together with
taylor strecker and taylor donahue it's
also taylor donahue's like favorite song
so the two of them like i just can't oh
wow you learned something new every day
i didn't know you guys had all this
going on and it's ben's go-to shower
song so like i hear it all the time oh
when he gets in the shower he's like
alexa play meatloaf
oh
yeah he was really upset there have been
a few celebrities in the last couple
years like really got to ben betty white
mm-hmm kobe mm-hmm meatloaf
yeah
she's just really excited because you
know for us like our whole lives are
like pop culture celebrity like we are
very vocally invested in certain people
but ben's not like that he just like
goes about and like gets influenced by
who he gets influenced by like right
betty white so it's just interesting to
see like the cycle of you know
celebrities like who makes an impact on
you really
and out of all the no no that wasn't a
question it's like you know there's
there's sorry that's like a lot to ask
of someone no i mean who makes an impact
on one yeah
you know of all the celebrities out
there
singers comedians etc like some people
just stick with you bob saget is another
one who just passed away
and you actually see the the news story
about john mayer i thought it was like
really mentioning you know he the plane
yeah
yeah do you want to share yeah it was
just this article basically saying that
john mayer was the one who paid for and
chartered a plane from
orlando to
la to get bob's remains back in time for
the ceremony because bob's jewish
and if you're jewish you have to be
buried like the day after you die or the
day extenuating circumstances asap yeah
asap so i thought that was very menchie
and it wasn't like you know a john mayer
published article it was like a source
really revealed it and did you watch the
instagram live of
um jeff ross and john mayer no
so they were like driving in this little
car
and they went on instagram live and they
were like we are they're obviously just
like really really close with bob and
his wife and are trying everything
to like be helpful so they had driven to
the airport they took an uber to the
airport and picked up bob's prius
because he drove himself to the airport
for his gigs and they were just talking
about how like you know bob was such a
star like he could have had a limousine
take him to the airport but he always
drove his prius because he was like a
workhorse and they were just like
getting really emotional in the car
because like this car was like symbolic
of like bob it was really really sweet
that's really sweet i saw that they
picked up his car but i didn't know that
they went live on the way and they were
just like sharing little stories it was
very sweet
oh wow
yeah so it's been just like a heavy time
year right like a beginning of the year
that feels like heavier than most yeah i
i feel that's how i feel yeah so sending
love to everyone yeah
okay switching gears some of our
favorite girlies jennifer is it our
favorite girlies who are brought to you
by frame bridge
it is yeah it can be why not
frame ridge makes it easier and more
affordable than ever to frame your
perfect your favorite things without
ever leaving the house which is perfect
when you're taking 91 steps a day like
me
add a gallery wall to your home office
or send the perfect gift from art prints
and diplomas to the photos just sitting
on your phone you can frame bridge just
about anything here's how it works go to
framebridge.com and upload your photo or
if you have something physical they'll
send you packaging to safely mail it in
preview your item online in dozen dozen
of frame styles and all gallery wall
layouts you could choose your favorite
or get free recommendations from their
extremely talented designers
the experts at frame bridge will custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang instead of the hundreds
you'd pay at a framing store their
prices start at 39 and all shipping is
free plus our listeners can get 15 off
their first order at frame bridge when
you go to framebridge.com and use code
toast you can order online of course but
they also have in-person designers at
their stores in
dc new york atlanta philly boston and
chicago so get started today frame your
photos or send someone the perfect gift
go to framebridge.com promo code toast
to save an additional 15 off your first
order when you go to frame bridge
f-r-a-m-e bridge b-r-i-d-g dot com promo
code toast frame bridge is re is
galvanizing the framing industry which
is archaic and expensive for literally
no reason
yes exactly i have some stunning photos
self-portraits framed around my home and
they make yourself of self-portraits
yeah they make for some beautiful pieces
of art in case you're looking you can do
a photo of yourself or a photo of me
whatever works whatever works or
me or a photo of bro or don't forget you
can really also actually do a photo of
theo
okay our next story jennifer coolidge
says ariana grande saved her career
during a dead zone can i tell you i'm so
i meant to text you that i wanted to do
this as a story i'm sorry oh good
oh okay good i think it's just like the
cutest sweetest thing a jennifer
coolidge renaissance is in the making
and it's all thanks to ari the american
pie actress credits the pop star for
reviving her film career and taking her
out of a slump coolidge starred in ari's
2018 music video thank you next in which
she played a version of herself from
legally blonde her character paulette
she told jimmy fallon it was the
beginning of a lot of cool things that
happened for me i was going through a
dead zone not much was going on then
ariana did this imitation on your show
and you encouraged her and then this
ball got rolling then she says her and
ari dm'd and ari invited her to be in
the music video
and since then she has appeared in
several high profile projects in the
last few years including promising young
woman swan song single all the way plus
of course the white lotus you know what
like
when i think back to how i experience
the resurgence
of jennifer coolidge i do i really
remember it starting with aria like [ __ ]
makes me want a hot dog real bad like it
really did happen that way and it was so
cool a of jennifer coolidge like totally
acknowledged because jennifer coolidge
is extremely talented and she probably
would have had a resurgence no matter
what but her to give all the credit to
ari was so cool and for ari just to be
like this cool everything of the sort
girl with like all this influence and
power like you just love to see it no
you love to see it and clearly happen in
such an organic way i don't think ari
woke up one morning and said i'm going
to revive jennifer coolidge's career
what today but it's just like the power
of ari and also like that video was so i
mean i'm sure you know she has a ton of
videos but that video was like a moment
in time i remember where i was when i
first saw it i was babysitting theo at
your house and we watched the premiere
together it was where was i
you were probably on tour because it was
2018. i remember watching like a car or
something
that tracks yeah
um
so i think this is just really cool and
i think we're all better off for having
jennifer coolidge back in our lives a
hundred percent thank you ari thank you
jen and you know what this reminds me of
i'm sure you didn't see it
but um
you know in the david dobrik joe rick
vlogs he has like a couple signature
songs that like he loves and so whenever
he ends a vlog he plays like dancing
queen there's like three songs and one
of them is this song by carolina liar
show me what i'm looking for
honestly these sound like great
great choices of course i love that song
so it's like an iconic old song and
david dobrik was on his podcast and his
friends surprised him with the lead
singer of carolina liar and the guy was
like getting so choked up he's like you
don't understand like you have saved me
i was living on the streets i was
homeless and like you know with youtube
like you get revenue and david's videos
are so big and he uses this song in
literally almost every single vlog that
has like
tens of 20s or 30s of millions of views
so he's just like putting money in this
and like really researching his career
and now he's like making content with
him it was so
it was such a nice moment and this is
what the jennifer coolidge thing
reminded me of because this just
happened like a week ago
oh my god that's beautiful i didn't
realize that that's where the story was
gonna go yeah and so he like performed
the song and david was like so excited
and then he was like no you don't
understand like you've literally saved
my life and david's like what are you
talking about he's like i had no money
like the music industry is just so
tough and like i had this breakthrough
song and then you know like [ __ ] happens
and david just like continually pumping
up the song and then getting other
people to stream it and david has so
many followers like literally change
this guy's life oh my god when was this
episode like a like a week and a half
ago like wow his friends got in contact
with the lead singer and then they were
like david we have surprise for you and
david was like really shook wow that's a
great story yeah it was cool not that
that's the same circumstances as
jennifer coolidge but it just reminded
me no yeah
love a story like that feel free to
share any time yeah um so thank you ari
thank you jen thank you jimmy fallon he
was a part of it too like if it weren't
for the crazy reach of those annoying
jimmy fallon videos on youtube we might
not be here yeah but no one does those
better than ari like that segment was
made for her
where she impersonates people like no
i've never seen anyone do it quite like
her no i've seen a lot of people
actually do it and it's painful and
cringy no and i think other people like
have like three people that they can do
who are like you know easily doable
though i'm i don't do impersonation so i
shouldn't judge but ari like is
an impersonation queen an impersonation
chameleon yes she can really do anyone
and obviously her best is celine dion
but
so good
so good
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story oh my god already already
and it's some weird legal news
it's the final story
i won't do the whole thing because
people have made their
opinions known their opinions known and
i'm here to please and entertain and not
torture but um and apparently that's
what i was doing so it's good to know
our fifth and final story anna de armas
fans are suing because she was cut out
of the movie yesterday
not yesterday no the movie yesterday
film titled the film titled in quotes
yesterday she was in the trailer for the
movie and then wasn't in the actual
movie and now two fans have filed a
federal class action lawsuit on friday
alleging they were duped into renting
the 2019 you know what
because anna appeared in the trailer you
know what that's actually fair like this
is there's so much false advertising
like when it comes to tv and movies and
that's fair you know what and maybe you
know ready you know what this reminds me
of watching the trailer for love hard
thinking heather mcmahon was gonna be in
it so much and they didn't put her in
enough and if i had rented it maybe i
would have sued but i got it for free
because i'm a netflix subscriber so
here's what's interesting so anna's
armist was meant to be in the movie she
was gonna play like the lead
character when he goes to l.a and is
like singing he was like she was gonna
play the girl that he was like wooing
there but then i guess the directors
felt like it took away from the
integrity of the main love story which
was between him and lily james so they
cut out anada armas completely um
but apparently there's been a suit like
this in the past someone in 2011 filed a
complaint involving the film drive
because they said that the film um the
trailer made it appear that the film
would be a high-speed action driving
film and she was not prepared for the
film's slow-paced interpersonal drama
punctuated with graphic violence
i love this right okay but she did not
win because they ruled that the trailer
demonstrates um like everything that's
in the trailer is in the movie if they
package it in a way no but
this is precedent for this because
everything in the trailer was not the
film yeah no and i feel like that
happens so often like you'll see a scene
in the trailer and then you're like wait
where was that in the movie no and you
know what i'm actually really glad that
there's some accountability happening
like because we all go it's actually
psychotic how we like all go spend money
and watch movies like that we know
actually nothing about and more often
than not they're either not like the
trailer at all or they're much worse
yeah
so
i i wonder what's gonna happen here
because it is false advertising she is
not in the film and especially because
like she's i mean it does i'm sure it
doesn't even matter that like she's a
big star and i wanted to see out into
armist and i didn't see her even if it
was someone renting the movie because
they thought like their kid was in it
and then the kid got cut but then like
i'm sure it's the same thing it's the
definition of false advertising like
yeah and i i'm no lawyer but i do think
these gals got a case and i'm fully i
think my full support
yeah it's two guys and i don't know how
much they're suing for but they should
at the very least get their rental
feedback which was 39.99 3.99 on amazon
prime 100 and you know i think the whole
concept that we like rent movies like on
our or like we buy apps and everything
and all these like amazon and apple you
can't get refunds like for anything like
what if i accidentally downloaded a 75
app one time you know
which did happen to me by the way
you accidentally downloaded it i
accidentally downloaded an app that was
75 and like there's no line to call like
what app is 75 it was this like cartoon
drawing app i downloaded the wrong one
literally don't ask okay but i swear to
god it happened maybe it was like 69.99
i was like oh [ __ ] like i realized one
second too late that i clicked the wrong
one there's no customer service there's
no live chat like what the [ __ ] apple
does have live chat and i actually since
we're talking about apple i just want to
bring something up that happened to me
um because you guys have all been on
this computer journey with me and last i
left you i told you i was ordering the
computer from the factory so it's going
to take a few weeks and but i was
willing to be patient to get the
computer that i wanted from the app
apple mac trillion dollar company the
biggest stock in the country you know i
want the computer that i want whatever
um i happen to be talking to lauren
elizabeth and she told me that she was
getting a new computer too and that she
was getting it in two days from
somewhere other than apple and i was
like oh [ __ ] mine should be here soon
though let me go check on it
my order was cancelled they never even
told me that it was canceled
did not send me an email and update
nothing all of my recent apple orders
now are canceled cancelled cancelled you
can't get a computer you can't get a
computer supply chain man
it's so crazy this trillion dollar
company yeah how where are the trillions
coming from if you can't literally can't
even pay to get a computer so what'd you
do you went to costco so i ordered a
computer from costco which is where
lauren elizabeth told me she was getting
hers so we know that but if i need a
computer i will go to costco yeah if you
need an apple computer go to costco make
it make sense make it make sense make it
make sense i don't know
so that's my story oh yeah anadarmas uh
hopefully we get an update
even if it's just the fee
that they get paid back
but they're also probably adding like
emotional distress legal and then then
if you see someone and you win they have
to pay your legal fees so you know what
i think this will be very interesting i
look forward to a movie being made about
this yeah and you know what if i sat
down to watch adam to arm us and she
wasn't there i would feel emotionally
distressed i would yeah especially like
as we were just saying you never know
who impacts you when anna armist might
have been one of those celebrities for
one of these guys yeah exactly i think
there's more to the story i hope they
get the justices who desperately deserve
i think so too and i think it sets a
good precedent and maybe it will keep
these trailer makers in line yeah no and
just like these overall marketing
departments from just spewing lies
yeah and what about where for anna de
armas like to just be cut from this
movie i mean i think that happens all
the time yeah and this movie was like
really before she popped off and it was
bad and
and it was atrocious and she should be
glad that she's not affiliated with it
she was saved she was saved but i'm sure
at the time she's like a budding actress
she's like in this movie that's you know
beatles it's going to be everywhere of
course billy james and she gets the axe
yeah who even knew that she went through
that no and now i have so much like
sympathy in my heart for all ada armas
has been through it must be
so hard to be a hollywood actress i'm
just crying on the inside
yeah i really like her i think she's a
great actress i've only seen her in um
knives out
so good so good knives out 2 is coming
soon is it yeah they're working on it so
is white lotus two and it's did you see
it's
taking sicily yeah and jennifer coolidge
will return
but that
that means that the crew from hawaii
won't be in it no except jennifer
coolidge i was kind of looking forward
to like the stability of having the same
people like arm i mean i guess armond
like lost his job a million times over
at this point but you know like having
the same setting and just like bringing
in it feels like a reality show yeah but
it's not so it's just gonna be a whole
different show yeah
cool um all right let's speak of shows
dive into the tv recap where we're gonna
start with salt lake city um brought to
you by third love third love does
comfort and so can you they're bras
underwear activewear and feel-good
all-day wear are designed to hug better
hold stronger and support longer third
love obsesses over each stitch so you
never have to think about how something
feels looks or wears the 100 0005 star
reviews do not lie
so third love is celebrating the
year-round love that endures your ride
or die best friend your favorite
cardigan your kids your loyal fur baby
and so you can celebrate valentine's day
with the luxe intimate gift set and
ultra soft loungewear that hug better
support longer and love you right back
so i've been wearing third love bras
like since i found out about the company
and they were like a life-changing brand
for me and then finding out that they
made pajamas which is obviously like a
category that's very near and dear to my
heart was just very exciting and the
pajamas are
literally just as good as the bra they
fit well they're like very supportive at
night they're breathable i think the
perfect pajama is a very specific
formula
and third love has
has nailed it and they've also nailed
just bras in general especially when it
comes to sizing they make it really easy
to find a bra that actually fits with
their um
fits with the fitting room quiz is what
you take it's like a personal shopper
but it's much better because it focuses
on size breast shape current issues with
your fit and your personal style to find
bras and underwear that are perfect for
you they've helped 18 million women find
their true bra size and by the way the
the if you've been battling with your
bras the key is knowing your size and i
did not know my actual size until i
started wearing third love bras i swear
in my life
they're also the largest donor of
undergarments in the u.s partnering with
organizations across the u.s they've
donated over 40 million dollars worth of
bras to help people in need feeling is
believing upgrade to everyday pieces
that love your body as much as you do so
right now you can get 20 off your first
order at thirdlove.com
toast that's 20 off at thirdlove.com
toast
great
okay let's talk about salt lake city it
was literally so infuriating
okay
so
we're in zion
and everyone's being unreasonable and i
don't really understand how we went from
you know this major news story about jen
shaw
and the fraudulence and the arrest on
camera
to literally villainizing meredith marks
i don't know how we got here but i do
know that like
everyone is the worst whitney has
overnight become the worst
jenny i've seriously in my life never
met a bigger loser like
and i honestly she probably won't return
to the show after what happened to her
on social media this week i heard she's
filming
oh really
well i can't stand her like she every
time she says something she thinks she's
doing something and somebody has to tell
her she's doing nothing it's giving
nothing no and she's constantly playing
a bad game of telephone like getting
information and then telling it to
someone else but like misrepresenting
the
the heart of the matter like the thing
about the private investigator was
cleared up in two [ __ ] seconds and it
was just infuriating i'm actually so
glad i'm so glad that we didn't recap
last week because it was just last
week's episode which i watched last
night was like a [ __ ]
every like i was after that episode i
was gonna be like like how do we have a
show anymore these women can't even like
they can't focus on one thing like they
can't focus on jen they can't focus on
mary they're like every little feeling
that bothers them they have to make it's
like a full-fledged fight because they
think that it'll make the show better
but we're getting so off course and you
know how i know they're doing a bad job
when i think after last night the person
who came out on top looking the best was
jen shaw
after last well yeah after last night um
first of all i agree i don't even know
where i stand i'm so perpetually
confused by the show and i think
meredith is who i
root for the most because i think she it
has the most sense and also behaves in a
way that's
like less like a reality tv star and
more just like i'm a person and you and
you [ __ ] with my family [ __ ] off i
don't care the fact that we're filming a
show like that just is never going to be
forgiven sure we can like get in the hot
tub and have a drink but i will never
forget what you did and i feel like
that's a very real human response as
opposed to like
lisa barlow who is the uh a political
housewife like she will say
but like i also kind of love her but she
will say and do anything to keep being
on the to be relevant to be on the show
but like that's that's what drives her
so and then that's fine by me
but it's interesting
i cannot listen to one more conversation
of like theorizing why meredith wasn't
on the sprinter van like i don't
understand why it's so difficult for all
these women who are all mothers to
understand
why
meredith marx just decided to take her
own car as opposed to spending six hours
in a van with gen cha after all and then
we found out that the she hired a
private investigator and the private
investigator surmised that there's a 90
chance the threats that
the death threats that are going to
meredith's house and meredith's family
are coming from gen cha so after we know
all of that they still don't understand
why she didn't get in the van and
they're pressing it so hard every meal
they don't stop even though she's giving
them the answer if only they pressed gen
shot like slightly about some of the
accusations a percentage of what they
they push on meredith for the reason she
wasn't in the van which is not hard to
understand no and even taking jen out of
it like these girls are [ __ ] annoying
like yeah
just who wants to be on a van with them
for six hours who wants to be in a van
with anyone for six hours when meredith
had the option the first time she
she flew private i think and when so
mary flew private and then the second
time they just flew
why would anyone subject themselves to
the van like the being in the van is
really not a part of the job like being
on the trip is a part of job i'm
surprised that meredith even stayed past
the first night like she is being a team
but sometimes like you need
personal space and boundaries and it's
like if i'm gonna be trapped in a house
with all of you people who are talking
like just the most random [ __ ] about me
for three days you know what i need
mentally to prepare to get there and
that includes not riding in the van
nothing has ever made more sense than
that to me and that the fact that they
can't get over it is so annoying also
like everyone was just annoyingly drunk
at the dinner and so not making a lot
oh my god it's infuriating you know what
lisa barlow was right about one thing
whitney heather bad weather the two of
them together are atrocious literally
and they think they're so funny and
quirky and smart and right about
everything and that like everything they
do is going to go viral
i've never found two housewives together
more annoying in my life and i've never
went from liking them so much to
literally can't even listening to them
they had a good first season it's liam
mcsweeney syndrome and now they think
they can do no wrong when they were
lying in the bed like trying to avoid
meredith
like
no i can't like and meredith was totally
right
and lisa barlow's like kind of the queen
of like
going to people's rooms at night and
like changing things yeah because i mean
i i i understand the move it's like
first of all she participated in an
unsavory conversation about someone that
she considers a friend she has a pit
about it this is at the me giving her
the benefit of the doubt yeah she has a
pit about it and she wants to go and
unburden herself and it's really like
more so for her than for the other
person like she feels guilty and she
needs to share
others might think such as whitney that
she is going and you know
you know
showing herself in a good light
admitting to her sins and throwing
everyone else under the bus i think it's
a mixture of books i think it's a
mixture of both too i just felt like the
whole episode like everyone was being
stupid and honestly there was just so
many cringy moments mostly coming from
jenny like any time she tries to stand
up and like say something in someone's
face she like just doesn't she doesn't
do it just it's a flop it's a flop and
like she's just consistently on the
wrong side of history like consistently
and i think she's just trying to gauge
and like why is she having so many
private conversations with jen shaw she
doesn't even know her i have no idea and
i think it must be hard to be a new
housewife and come on to this scene
because the lines are so blurred of like
who's friends with who who's loyal to
who like you would have thought that
like if jenny's friends with lisa that
means jenny's
friends with meredith but no because
lisa and meredith can barely stand each
other i don't know where they stand now
to me that friendship like is uh feels
like a loss whenever anyone comes on the
show
whenever anyone comes on the show and
they're friends for say minimum five
years like have been actual friends
before this and the show like finds a
way to come between them
or they they allow the show to come
between them it does make me sad and so
worse and i think that the two of them
i would like to see them get back to
being like good friends who have each
other's backs me too but like i don't
know how honestly
meredith could like live with herself if
she let lisa back into her home after
lisa like so weirdly out of nowhere
became best friends with jen shop this
second gen shot started saying
homophobic things about meredith's son
like i don't know meredith doesn't seem
like the type of girl can get over that
right and then next week um what she
says about [ __ ] half of new york
right meredith
meredith doesn't forget
no and i wouldn't either and it's
annoying because i agree with you i
really want to like lisa and for me
every i start to like her more when
she's like a good friend to meredith and
it's like she's becoming a worse friend
every episode
yeah agreed and did you watch watch what
happens live last night no
lisa was on and i think like things
between her and meredith are strained
but i do feel like she's trying to get
back on meredith's good side because all
of the answers that she gave to stuff
were like put meredith in as like a
flattering light right well she's also
since the show has started airing she's
been like very vocal on watch weapons
live and just like podcasts and stuff
that she's like anti-gen shot she can't
be friends with someone who like
committed these crimes but she's like
acting very differently on the show
she's just so fraudulent like i will
never believe she'll say the sky is blue
i'm like but
but it's not
yeah i i just i'm like but why what
motivates you to say that
where are you coming from and she's like
what are you getting out of this and she
says all the time she hates how everyone
thinks she's like so calculating and
manipulative and she's like really just
like living her life which i want to
believe but like i've been i've been
misled
yeah and then these people just like
talk in circles around each other to the
point that like i really don't care but
like when
at one point jen said like that she
really believes that mary and meredith
in some way are connected to the fbi
showing up at beauty lab like
is the most nonsensical thing i've ever
heard in my life and i can't believe
that i'm spending my time watching
people on television who could believe
something liberated who could believe
something like that and even though we
no one reunion and andy doesn't
immediately point out how moronic that
is that like random citizens don't get
nine-year investigations being put like
if it's not squashed like i would be so
annoyed if they treat it like an actual
possibility like yes you can call a tip
in on someone but
it's just so stupid like i can't i can't
this the show's actually making me so
frustrated yeah no it it is and we've
lost sight of we've lost the thought and
i was just like
how how how's this happen it was like
it's so weird to me it was nice to see
but it's also so weird that they like
one the night before they could not even
sit around the table and have a
conversation and then the next night
like they are having the time of their
lives
i don't
i don't get it
i'm glad that they were able to mend
fences and
have a good time
but how can how is that possible
sociopathic
it's crazy i have no idea
that was one of the big that always
happens on trips you get a rough start
you get the fight out and then like
everyone comes together but like
that was one of the biggest leaps i've
ever seen yeah it was nuts it was not it
was unnatural yeah
um so yeah like it's just chaos every
episode and i'm actually not enjoying it
which is annoying because this is
supposed to be like the benchmark season
of the franchise that'll give it like
you know we'll be talking about this
we will not be like these women have
dropped the ball so hard they're not
doing this storyline any justice
and i can't period period
um
and then i finished watching ted lasso
which was so good and yes it still is
this like happy fun go lucky show
but like there was some drama and when i
so
when i spoiler alert
when i found out when trent crim who i
love the independent
told ted lasso that you know nate was
his source i like was gagged like i was
never been so shocked in my whole life
and then i was able to kind of figure
out that like he was definitely going to
be the coach for rupert's team so that
like end thing didn't really surprise me
but the end thing that's what i was
saying when i was recaptured i was like
the last second like even though it's
not a cliffhanger e show at all like it
totally shocked me i thought the coach
was gonna turn around it's like this
coach with gray hair so i thought he was
gonna turn around and have a great like
just be a random guy with a gray
mustache and be like fake fed faso right
and when it was nate
i was shook to the core i was shook to
my core but i had predicted it but i had
not predicted nate becoming like i knew
he was like you know acting out blah
blah blah and i thought like ted you
know was gonna give him one of his pep
talks and put him back in this place
i did not expect this villain origin
story from nate but you know what i
really kind of appreciated like
how realistic like that's how people
become monsters like you give them one
ounce of kindness and they become
monsters like it was just very accurate
in my opinion it was so sad to watch i
don't think that happens all the time
but it can happen and
now looking back it's like all the signs
were there and it started very slowly
and even just the way he treated the guy
who replaced him that's how you know he
was doing mom's games
yes but then like even the spitting on
the mirror is like his
his power pose like the first time i saw
it i was like ew someone has to clean
that up and then it just became like
extremely disrespectful that when he
would do it like wherever he was
and
it was just
it was shocking to see
yeah so like i'd like that the show was
kind of taking this turn now um but
everyone's like evolving i love that roy
kent came back to coach and kiele is
starting her own pr firm and sam and
rebecca that was shocking when
when he was okay when when she was like
texting that guy on banter and like she
didn't know who he was but obviously it
was going to be someone we knew like
obviously i thought it was ted
oh my god well first of all you know
that
so a few weeks ago after i watched the
movie love hard when i said that there
should be a dating app that's no
pictures and someone's people said
that's a story line on ted lasso so i
was really excited to see how it played
out in my version of the app you do have
names
and like uh you also can have like talk
about your profession yeah it's just no
photos not everything else because then
you get into a situation like
that either murderer no or like with
someone that works for you and it's
inappropriate so i did not think that
they were going to go through with the
relationship like because it really is
crossing a lot of lines but i you know i
want love for sam and i want love for
rebecca and if they found it with each
other then then that works and i think
it just is proof that we need an app
like this 100
yeah um so all in all i really enjoyed
the show there were two and you were
telling me this there were two episodes
where like me and ben i i would have
finished the whole show on saturday
night but i watched two such atrocious
episodes in a row me and ben were
falling asleep the first episode which
was like the
what's this coach's name beard beard
beard the beard origin story like where
he like had that terrible night and i
don't know why they were like being
really cryptic like i thought he was
gonna die did you
no i don't remember what i because he
was like sofa clamped when he said
goodbye to ted at the stadium after
losing to man city
and he was like kind of like depressed
and like all this bad stuff kept
happening to him i'm like oh no is he
gonna do something like bad i don't know
and then nothing happened so i was like
what the [ __ ] was the point of this
episode
the point of the episode was apparently
they turned in 10 episodes to apple tv
and apple tv said we need 12. so they
stuck in two evergreen episodes the
beard night
and this and the funeral which both of
them if you take out don't change the
storyline at all i wish someone had told
me that i would have skipped them like
they were so bad yeah they were they
were actually the beard one especially
the beard one
um but the christmas episode i don't
know if that's season one or season two
was probably my favorite like christmas
holiday episode of a tv show like in a
really long time not only was it like
giving you all the holiday feels like so
sweet the story line about roy kent's
niece who had bad breath i swear to god
like i actually me and ben we could not
breathe like we had left so hard we
reminded a hundred times that obviously
that iconic scene i think you might be
dying
so good like just pure comedy genius i
enjoyed it so much yeah that is so funny
but anyways so i was saying like i do
feel like you know this the show is very
like light and happy-go-lucky but there
are like darker elements at play
and i don't know if it's just like our
culture has a really um
strange relationship to alcohol but it
does feel like everyone on the show has
a drinking problem yes and i don't know
if they're going to address it or that's
just like how we approach drinking these
days or it's like drinking in british
culture because like the pubs and
everything the pumps yeah but i think
it's it's all about like i don't think
it's a british thing like ted they just
every time there's like something
stressful they're just like pounding
beers like it's it's copious amounts of
alcohol and and things in shows like
everything is placed like for a reason
like every number of drinks like
everything is intentional so i do feel
like it's leading us to like someone
here
has a drinking like or but i also think
that there's more than one every time
rebecca takes a sip of champagne she
downs the whole glass in one slip right
no and i just that's not like healthy
behavior so i i feel like there's more
forces working at play here i had
thought um in the beginning that like
they're always showing ted with alcohol
like ted might struggle with alcohol
down the line yeah i think so too
especially um
especially when he's like going through
it that's what he turns to which i think
a lot of people you know when you're
having a hard day or a rough time like
yeah i'm gonna take the edge off but it
seems more pointed than that on the show
and i i feel like that's an intentional
move yeah
um so thank you for the recommendation i
very much enjoyed it
i'm so glad to hear it when have i ever
led you astray
um that show on acorn
wrong a place to call home
if you're looking for a new show that's
just gonna sweep you off your feet the
magic of love family and everything
community of the sort
download download acorn tv wait you guys
i actually have a code for you from the
redheads and i'm gonna share it one
month free of acorn okay love your life
um this is not an ad for this show but
go to acorn
acorn dot tv and use code book to get
your first 30 days free and binge watch
the show a place to call home
guys this wasn't even like a stage job
it will stick with you forever
um the last thing i wanted forever was
last night's forever
oh last night okay what's no going on
with the kids penis honestly like maybe
this is a hot take i thought it was a
really boring episode even though like
it had this moment in it that
like we saw on the trailer a few weeks
ago and people like the sound has been
going viral on tick tock and they're
just like waiting for the moment where
cassie says i have never
ever been happier and like we got in
like it was just like it was a daydream
like she didn't actually say that you
know she just wished that she did you
know oh
um so it was like kind of a boring
episode but we did get like a cal
jacob's origin story which obviously
made him extremely sympathetic because
you get this romance of like him and his
best friend growing up who are both
closeted and they have this like one
night where they realize like they're
both like in love with each other and
it's like
so cute then the next morning he finds
out his girlfriend's pregnant and that
girlfriend is actually his wife right
now so like it just we never got to see
the calendar story and like we know why
he's so evil not that it justifies any
of his behavior
but it was an interesting i like i liked
going back in time to that little
era of calendar a ship um but back in
like modern the present really nothing
happened and there was like this weird
editing slice of like lexi's play i
wasn't on board with it like i don't
know i just maybe i'm spoiled because i
binged it all at once so i'm used to
like things happening and this is like
two episodes in a row where like i
really wouldn't say anything happened
i think that's
what's happening
is you binge a show and then you have to
get used to watching it episodically and
it changes things right because like i
can tell you you know all of season one
like all the things that happened and
now i'm just like what the hell has even
happened like what really happened this
week you know kat is you know having a
hard time with her boyfriend
um
nate brought maddie flowers instead of
cassie the scenes of cassie gouache and
ice rolling and getting up at 4am to get
ready for school because she wants to
look cute for nate like
that was funny
and she like keeps showing up checking
like more and more crazy looks that like
literally by the end of the week she
looks like the
the school plays oklahoma and she teased
her hair so much they thought that she
was auditioning for the play
oh that's funny but yeah nothing really
nothing happened so like
except rue once again just being
dumb like so i told you you know she's
struggling with addiction and like she
was
in
uh
recovery
of course she's not anymore
um and so not only is she like lying to
everyone around her about being in
recovery she's now decided to start
selling drugs which is just obviously a
dangerous dumb thing to do
so because she knows like it'll get her
access to drugs she'll get herself free
drugs and then she'll like money for
drugs so i think in her head it makes a
lot of sense and of course you know
she's an addict so that's her only
focus at the moment but she's just not
being wise you know there's so much
violence in euphoria and it's all around
the drugs and she's next
whoa that's a lot for the campers it's a
lot for the campers and it really was
not like a great episode so i'm gonna
need something to happen like now
okay or you could batch save them and
batch them i can't because if i scroll
i get so many spoilers so like last
night i was being such a loser like
literally watching it 901 oh wow that's
losery but are you not able to like mute
you should be able to mute
like topics on tickets you should that's
actually a really good idea but they
don't do that okay free idea tick tock
once again here at the morning shows
just giving out free billion dollar
ideas i heard my tick tock is making a
resurgence
i went on your tick tock like on friday
and just watched every single one of
your old videos you were so good like
and your apartment has really good light
so you were just like making premium i i
mean i said that you should get back on
tick tock i would enjoy that so much but
you won't but it's you need a hobby
it was a moment in time
and you know you're loving it i feel
like if you have the app and went on
and logged in like you would see people
are still commenting like living for
the content that's so sweet um
yeah it's hard to separate the like
creating on tick tock from scrolling on
tick tock and i think the scrolling on
tick tock is what is really toxic and
takes up like all of your time in your
brain cells and that's that's what i'm
trying to avoid um but you also can't
create on tick tock without scrolling
and seeing what the trends are and then
you just like fall down the rabbit hole
so it's all it's almost like i couldn't
just like hop on there unless i was just
posting like videos from ac's diary
which also works maybe she'll come back
but right now her phone has been
confiscated because she's been spending
too much time on it
yeah ac is grounded in a big way
um and so am i because that's the end of
our show
yes
and we love you guys thank you so much
for listening to the morning tell us the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past life stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast and where
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cats box all the places wherever
you listen to podcast find us the
morning shows and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing day don't forget to stream my
song hundred percent never too late to
become a redhead follow jackie austria
on instagram follow girl with no job on
instagram we've got a big call with our
lawyers today about our instagram for
the morning toast we are on top of it we
love you have a great day goodbye
goodbye
wait
okay we're here people
somebody left a comment like at the end
of the episode sometimes you say love ya
and sometimes you don't and it really
affects their day so i just want to make
sure that you can do it i didn't realize
that they say it at the end of the
episode that's always how i hang up the
phone yes
love you bye